so here's some fairly unconventional
advice I think that if you are really
struggling with a course or failing it
then either that subject matter really
isn't for you or you need to get better
friends and often I think that last part
getting better friends is pretty much
what it comes down to the advice that
I'm going to talk about mainly applies
for university level subjects and my
experience and studying at University
and how to get good grades there but I
think this probably applies at school as
well I think it's almost kind of obvious
at that level that if you're friends
with people that are sort of leading you
astray things aren't going to work out
well for you but I'm more talking about
people that are actually you know really
keen to study really came to get good
grades but for some reason they just
don't and this phrase if you get bad
grades you need better friends isn't
actually something I came up with myself
it's something that I heard a professor
telling to the students in his class so
at that level I guess the professor
wanted the students to learn and do well
but he was aware enough that I guess
there was a lot of material to learn and
that for student trying to learn at all
on their own they're just not going to
do as well as someone who's going about
it a bit smarter and is working with
other people and when I say working with
other people of course I'm not talking
about copying off people or like not
learning the content for yourself but
doing it smartly working in teams to
figure out problems that alone would
have taken you way too long to figure
out like you can actually use other
people to your advantage in a way that
benefits all of you
of course again like there are
situations when you can't work with
other people at universities so on like
take-home tests or exams or like assess
work but for assignments and studying
and all that sort of stuff it's kind of
expected that you would work with
someone it's it's not expected that
someone's going to be able to learn all
the course content and do all the
assignments like purely on their own I
don't think that's a smart thing to do
at all so the way I see it is that
actually if you're studying at
University then the most important skill
that's going to help you get good grades
is being able to socialise and being
able to make friends with strangers and
and communicate and work in a team now I
know that for like a lot of you guys
study maths or physics that subject like
that because that's what I talk about on
my channel and often socializing isn't
our most favorite activity in fact like
I in person I'm an incredibly shy and
socially awkward person so if someone
gave me this advice ages ago it would
probably horrify me and I would say no
like learning physics shouldn't be about
how good you are at socializing it
should be all about your inherent like
mathematical skills and you should be
able to be like that loan genius and and
you would think like Einstein never had
to work in a team he just came up with
all these series on his own but you know
like I've been through the Uni system
and I've sort of seen how this works and
I've come to the realization that there
is no such thing as the lone genius but
that's sort of a whole nother topic
essentially the way that a lot of Muniz
work in the way at least mine definitely
did was your to get the most out of the
course and to get the most out of what
the lecturer is offering you and and all
the opportunities available to you you
really need to work with other people
and if you don't have friends in a class
it's going to be really hard for you no
matter how smart you think you are so my
biggest study tip is to find some
friends early in your course and you
know if you don't know how to find
friends here's some ideas like the most
valuable friends I guess I made at
university were the people that I met in
like the front row of lectures it seems
to be then the people that sit in the
front row are like really keen and often
really friendly really open to like I
don't know working together and and
having chats about the content and I
think in the front row of lectures you
can find some really valuable people I
think uni and finding friends is always
harder for people that don't live on
care
and don't have that sort of automatic
friend group that comes along with like
living with other people but I think it
really is possible to meet friends and
Lich's it can be as easy as just like
asking them what their major is and then
asking them you know about some
assignment you have guys have coming up
whether they like to work together and
the more momentum you can build around
sort of a study group and like add more
people into it and and really build that
family and that sense of belonging and
and comradeship like around your course
it's gonna be a lot better for you so
let me give you some examples from my
life and what I'm talking about here now
today is actually my 23rd birthday and
it's the anniversary of a time back in
first year when I spent my birthday like
having a real miserable time in a
mathematical modelling lad it was an 8
a.m. lab on a Friday and I mean that
timing is awful about why this was a
really awful day for me it was because I
just had no friends in this class I
guess the content wasn't even that
difficult like I remember this
particular lab we were on MATLAB and we
were like trying to code in some
functions to like generate trig
functions like the sine function through
a Taylor expansion we were coding it and
like I feel like this would kind of be
really easy for me to do now it's not
even hard in concept but at the time I
just had like no idea what I was doing I
would I don't know how to use MATLAB I
didn't know anything about Taylor
expansion but I also just had no friends
in this class and it was the only class
like this because it was the only class
I was taking different to like my main
group of like solid friends who had made
in my other courses and I was just like
sitting in this room and everyone felt
really unapproachable I didn't know
anyone and I just feel like I had to
struggle through it alone and I was like
that's fine I can just like read up you
know explanations for this and try and
figure it out myself but honestly it was
just miserable like I took so long to
try and figure it out and if I just had
like someone beside me who I felt
comfortable like talking to and being
like oh like I you up to the Stepp like
how do you think we go from here it
would just would have been so much
better
and it was actually after I had such a
bad time in that course but I was like
I'm never gonna let that happen again
I'm always going to make sure you know
in the first week of a new course my
priority is going to be making sure I
have a friend in this class like that I
know someone and that I can I can always
ask someone for help and I think that
was really so important for me was
prioritizing not letting myself be alone
and struggling alone in a course the way
that I would work with my friends who I
made in classes that maybe we'd like sit
together in lectures and maybe joke
around a little bit or like talk about
around them stuff but then like when it
came to doing assignments often there
would be like facebook messenger chats
or groups or something and that would be
like you know how do you do this certain
type of question and then people would
sort of explain it to you and and it
really worked both ways because if you
were struggling with something you could
ask your friends for help and they would
often you know get you out of the rut
you're in much faster than you could get
out yourself but also if you are the
person who already understands what's
going on and you'd probably could just
do this particular assignment all by
yourself no worries I think it's really
valuable for you to help other people
out and to not be a jerk but to you know
really bring people along with you and I
think it really benefits you because you
are getting practice explaining
something and you're actually making
sure you understand it better yourself
you're solidifying things and you've got
these people who sort of like are really
grateful for your help so I really think
it goes both ways if you're struggling
in class make it your priority to make
good friends and people that you know
are aligned with what you're trying to
achieve in the class and aren't going to
drag you down and are really going to
help you get there and even if you are
doing really well maybe go out of your
way a little bit to help others to still
appreciate the value of friends when
you're studying and to know that it also
values you to explain things to other
people thanks for watching